hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here
and today we are going to learn how to
deal with the king's gambit
now when i start my chess carrier i was
an e4 e5 player
until i made the king's gambit
and
i was so afraid and i lost so many games
that i completely switched my opening
reprotha from e5 to e6 or the c6
and that can be the case of many
uh the reason is king's gambit is a
quite a bit attacking opening
and not only that
there are many lines i have to say many
complex lines exist inside the king's
gambit
which are very hard to play as a second
player
and especially white has prepared all
the lines then it will be very difficult
for black
to take a good position out of it
anyways
in today's lecture
we'll learn how to completely defuse the
king's gambit
and
the lines which i have suggested they
are not attacking lies
but what those lines can provide you is
a very safe and a sound
opening
which
you can come out against the king's
gambit and a second player can look
forward for an equal or slightly more
than equal middle game
okay so let's
start
the king's gambit occurs when white
plays e4
and here there are a few ways where
king's gambit can be occurred black can
either play e5 and black responds with
the f4 this is a proper king's gambit
and the another way is
black can play a knight c6 which is a
nameservice defense and after f4 black
replies with the e5
now
as usual uh in this
in this opening there are many traps
exist
uh by the way the system i'm
recommending to you is known as adelaide
counter to give you a brief history uh
this counter was initially introduced at
the adelaide and it won a consolation
price and during that time people were
thinking that this is a complete
reputation to the king's gambit but
nevertheless in recent years there have
there have been some research done on
this
and some players have come out with very
good lines for the white as well
so i have considered all those
approaches
and i have covered every single thing
over here so you do not need to worry
okay
so
here
uh
as usual
every single line has some opening chest
straps and this line is
not apart from that so here uh if
especially if your opponent is playing
in three minutes or bullet game
if we likely to make this mistake which
is f cross e5
we have the stunning move queen check
and if the
g3
then we have we nab the rook in the
corner
and if king goes to e2
then we can give this chair and after
king goes to f2 we can give this bishop
c5 check and white king will not survive
longer
so there is a one trap exist in here
which you should always look out anyways
the more
general response will be
knight f3
and here comes the adidas counter
start with the move f5
now you can see over here the tension
has been built up in this four squares
and there are every chance
that white can goes wrong over here and
i have covered each and every single
line from here onwards
so for example
what we will do first is we'll go to go
through the less dangerous to the most
dangerous reply of the white
okay so the least
dangerous or i have to say it's a
blunder move by wide which is knight
cross e5 and uh
it's a very easy line here from onwards
for the black so black will first
capture the knight and after white
recapture
we again go to our main trap which is
queen h5
and again if the g3 then the loop loses
and if the king comes forward you will
give this track and after king f2 will
play bishop c5
so
again you will you will always look out
for those kind of traps
anyways after uh
f cross e5
uh again this is also one kind of
blunderbolt because black can reply with
the f cross e4 and now you can see that
knight
does not have any good squares
and the only square left is it has to go
back
and there are many variation exists from
here words but i recommend the very
simple one is
you capture that pawn and black is a
pawn up and please note queen check does
not do any harms to the black because
black knight can come back and after
knight c3 black can play knight f6 and
you can see it's not only attacking the
queen but once the queen goes back
we can look forward for the d file
so
those two lines are
not at all good for the white
so let's
uh look at some serious approach by the
way
so for example uh white can play this
passive move which is d3
well
it's d3 it
looks uh solid and good for the wide but
the main drawback is you can see this
bishop is no longer comes out
and that means white has a very least
chance of attacking
and a very simple and equal game can we
go like this so black will respond with
the d6 and after
uh knight c3 knight f6 bishop e2 bishop
p7 both to side castle and we have
equal middle game happens
okay that is d3
now
let's see some of the aggressive reply
of the white so white can play
this move which is e cross f5
now against this
we will
transposition our line to a more
superior version of folk via counter
gambit and where here black plays e4
and after knight to e5 we'll play knight
f6 i will show you one of my game which
will give you a rough idea how to handle
this positions so my opponent plays
knight c3 i play d5 and here he plays
bishop b5 i protect by my knight by
queen to d6 and after he play d3
i grab the pawn bishop takes f5 and
after he castle
i played a6 so now he captured my knight
i recaptured and then he captured my
pawn i recaptured with the knight and
after rook to e1 i played bishop to e7
and you can see the position is roughly
balanced but i prefer black because it
has a more space in the center and
nevertheless black will castle short
in the next move so that will be a very
easy
game for the black
okay so that is
e cross f by
now
here
uh
the most logical reply by the white is
knight to c3
but against this
we have two good lines so
what we are going to do here first we
are going to capture this pawn
so you can see its pressurizing the
knight so here white has a two reply if
knight crossed e5 then again in one of
my game
i played knight f6
and after bishop b5 i played knight to
d4 attacking the bishop so he retrieved
the bishop then i played c6 so blunting
the diagonal and then once the castle i
played bishop c5 going for the discovery
so he his he parked his king in the
corner with king to h1 and then i castle
and now you can see
my very simple planning is to go d6 and
d5 and
black will have a very good game from
here onwards
so there is one sample line can drones
if the upper and take with the knight
cross e5
now
here after this capture there is another
move for the white which is knight takes
e4
well against this
black get a very very comfortable and
probably
more than equal game so black can play
d5 and after the knights goes to c3 we
can play e4
and
after knight to e5 knight to f6
you can see a very easy game for the
black case and see this see these two
pawns
they are giving a good space to the
black
uh they stated earlier that there has
been some research has done on this line
and
the recent approach are very aggressive
and uh one of the im
one of the very popular i am has
suggested a move is known as
d4
so it's a system against that delayed
counter
now against this
in his video he suggested only f cross
e4 which i don't agree with him
the the correct move here is e cross d4
and here white has a few reply
now let's deal with them one by one so
first move is if byte can play e5 well
against this very simple line you play
bishop e4 check and after bishop d2 you
play bishop c5
and
this is one of my game so my opponent
plays c3 i played knight a6 and after
queen c2 i played d6 so he grabbed the
pawn
i i grabbed the pawn with the bishop and
uh here he played knight c3 i played
knight to g4 attacking the f2
that leads forcefully capturing my
bishop and then i recapture with the
knight and after queen chat my knight
comes back
and
after he recapture the pawn i take with
the queen and here he done a queen side
castle so again you you can expect this
kind of thing from the attacking player
of the king's gambit
well uh there's no need to worry over
here because i simply played bishop to
e6 and after he played bishop to e3
attacking my queen
i simply put it to
v4 and you can see
the opening turns out very well here and
i i'm already attacking his bishop
initially i won this game
so that's a simple line if
e5 happens right can here capture the
pawn so
e cross f5 well against this i propose
you play bishop to c5
and a simple line runs like this so
bishop d3
knight f6 and the both the side castle
and
here the position is roughly equal but i
prefer black because the d pawn is
cramping white knights to come out and
not only that it's very hard for white
to get the d pawn and
it's more easier for the black to get
the f pawn
so that is e cross f5
now
the more aggressive reply is knight
cross d4
and against this i propose you play
knight f6 and again there are two lines
goes from here
if your opponent play e5
then i suggest you play knight takes and
after queen takes you play knight e4 now
you can see there is a nasty trap
looming which is bishop to c5 and if
opponent is careless you can trap him
with this move
but anyways if you are not going to play
this move bishop to e3
then you can play bishop to c5 anyways
and after queen to d3 you can simply
capture that bishop and after queen
recapture you can play d5
and you can again you can see
the
king's gambit has been totally diffused
and black emerge with a very superior
position
the last regressive reply is white can
greedily capture another pawn
so after knight f6 white can go with
this knight cross f5 well against this i
propose you take the pawn knight cross
e4
and
you don't need to worry about the
diagonal
so
for example white can play this bishop
to d3 but here simply you can drop back
the knight to f6 and a sample line uh
can turns like this so this has happened
in one of my game so my opponent plays
castle over here i give the check he
plays bishop to e3 i capture the bishop
then he recapture by the knight and then
i play d5
and now you can see by the arrow i'm
threatening to go d4
so that will embarrass the knight so he
played c3 and i castle and you can see
black has a two open file to walk out a
good attack
i hope you enjoy my video and learn
how to simply defuse the king's gambit
the lines which i have shown you are
very safe
and the most important thing is
it will frustrate the attacking players
of the king's gambit and you have all
chances of getting a win out of it
well best of luck for playing this line
and
feel free to comment on my video i'll
meet you soon bye